and they go up against sean manaya the
28 year old from northwest indiana who
ek was really rocky in his first four
starts has really sharpened up in his
last three outings
took a big cut on that high heater from
mania for a first strikeout to open the
day
that'll bring up manny machado
slow roller towards the excellent matt
chapman tough play to make and that gets
under olson and on to second will go
machado two down for austin nola another
0-2
bouncing ball to the left side for
chapman
clean play to close out the frame they
leave machado stranded the athletics are
coming up and today they deal with the
24 year old from austin texas pretty
good flow for chris paddock
good fast ball that freezes laureano for
called strike three here's matt olson
one two and it's ripped into right field
that's a base hit for olson that'll
score a run
a little bit of a slip and right by will
myers and that may end up being enough
to bring home two how about that for
olson he'll walk into third base to
drive in a pair and the a's are on top
of
and that gives sean manaya some cushion
as he enters
the second inning of work there's a 2-2
to myers and he waves at another high
fastball that's already three strikeouts
for sean manaya
one-two to jake cronin worth
and he waves and misses at the change so
good start for sean manaya he's got four
k's already
we're lucky enough to be joined by
fernando tatis jr who's playing
shortstop again for the padres today's
man we're having a great time over here
we're building something fun and the
boys are playing with passion i think
that's a big part and we're just fitting
one from each other man everybody just
on the same train track over here runner
going a big jump hyme takes the pitch
for a ball throw to second into center
field but scotty's gonna tie it up there
on the bag one away and that'll bring up
jonah heim
pass prunenworth into right field
piscotty will get the hold sign but he's
going to run through myers with a little
bit of trouble in right and biscotti
scores i'm into second it's three to
nothing athletics
now tommy stella who's singled and
scored back in the first the payoff
into right field and that one's going to
get down to score another run time is in
and into second base with an rbi double
is tommy lestella it's four to nothing
outlets
eric hosmer who's got a grand slam this
year is at the plate
osmer swings away to second la stella to
short machine the relay not in time
pophar comes in and scores and the
padres are on the board still two away
and runners at the corners for austin
nola there's a 1-1
vola in the air to center pretty well
struck loriano though is there at the
track and that'll do it for the padres
in the third
cuties aboard and here is machado who
has singled twice
2-1
back
[Music]
[Applause]
to close out the frame in the fifth
one two to machine is off the glove of
the catcher nola piscotti hustling into
second
we'll bring up the nine hitter jonah
heim who's one for two today had his
first big league rbi
[Applause]
into center field that's down for a base
hit here comes the throw from a good
centerfielder and grisham but they throw
a little short piscotty scores and the
a's extend the advantage back to four
it's five to one
luis patino on for the ninth time facing
ramon loriano
l'oreal going way back and he hammers a
home run a two-run shot
off of petunia
his fifth of the year and a 3-1 frame
for the oakland days to extend the lead
to six
grossman is over three today
one and two
on the ground diving stabbed by coleman
from the glove tatis was able to pick it
off the deck for the out at second
couldn't turn the double play but jake
cronenworth has really shown off the
range a couple of times already in this
series and throughout the season runners
at the corners for piscotty
on the ground and into right field a
base hit for piscotty that will score
canna
on the third base goes grossman and it's
eight to one a's here in the seventh
here's
austin nola who doubled in his last trip
swings away first pitch deep fly ball
back at the wall and over the fence it's
gone
austin nolo with his first
home run as a san diego padre
his sixth of the
year and padres with their first run
since the third frame
so here is mitch moreland
one two on moorland
and he chases the high fastball
hendricks finishes off the ninth inning
and the athletics
even up this series to snap a
season-long three-game skid
to set up the rubber game on sunday
afternoon against these padres